y
[Música]
70 días de la guerra en ucrania las
autoridades del país aseguran que
perdieron comunicación con las personas
atrincheradas en la siderúrgica a sus
talent mariupol quien denuncia que los
rusos redoblaron sus ataques contra la
fábrica pues comenzaron bombardeos por
tierra aunque moscú lo niega tendremos
reporte desde la vecina ciudad de
shakuri pto
en francia se fortalece la izquierda de
cara a las legislativas de junio los
socialistas alcanzaron un principio de
acuerdo con el partido francia insumisa
este colectivo fue el más votado de la
izquierda de las presidenciales y ahora
lidera la coalición a la que lleva se
unieron los ecologistas y los comunistas
la inflación de eeuu obligó a la reserva
federal a aumentar las tasas de interés
en medio punto porcentual el incremento
más grande que ha anunciado desde el año
2000 según su presidente será un powel
podría no ser el único
bienvenidos a esta sección informativa
de france 24 lo salude nuevo mar y
aclara calle y comenzamos con la
actualidad de la guerra en ucrania rusia
anunció que atacaría a las líneas de
suministro con las que la otan provee
armas a ucrania luego de esto quiere
denunció que moscú estaba bombardeando
estaciones de ferrocarriles y otros
objetivos de líneas de suministro uno de
los ataques estaría en mariupol el
gobierno local afirma que la arremetida
rusa aumentó y que por primera vez están
atacando por tierra a la fábrica as of
tal con tanques sin embargo moscú lo
niega y dice que sólo está repeliendo la
ofensiva de los ucranianos
el alcalde de mariupol vadim boychenko
agregó que ya no tienen comunicación con
los militares y los civiles que resisten
en la acería
en medio de estos ataques trescientos
cuarenta y cuatro civiles fueron
evacuados de la fábrica de as hostal
este miércoles según el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski antes
cientos de personas más salieron de la
planta de mariupol y después de dos días
de camino llegaron a la vecina ciudad de
sap orilla la vice primera ministra
ucraniana irina bereziuk afirmó que en
la siderúrgica siguen miles de personas
atrapadas incluidos niños nuestra vida
especial catalina gómez ángel nos cuenta
más desde shapouri cha este parqueadero
a la entrada a la ciudad de sap orilla
se ha convertido en el lugar soñado de
miles y miles de personas que huyen de
ciudades en el sur de ucrania no sólo de
mariupol donde ya llegaban más de 130
personas que vivían de la ciudad sino
también de otras ciudades que están en
control de las fuerzas rusas desde hace
ya varias semanas como melitópol y
verdad este es el caso de tamara y este
plan a que llegaron hoy
piquín muy pic y es difícil irse es
difícil y probablemente la mayoría de la
gente no quiera irse por eso es muy
difícil ellos los rusos podemos decirlo
de esta manera son muy abruptos
ellos exigen tarjetas sin auriculares
cigarrillos revisan los teléfonos
revisaron todas mis fotos todos los
chats e telegram y buscaban la bandera
ucraniana o cualquier cosa relacionada
con la simbología ucraniana
en este parqueadero se sigue esperando
que más personas puedan huir de esas
herida de azúcar donde cientos de
personas siguen todavía en esos refugios
subterráneos y están asediadas por esas
fuerzas rusas sin embargo poco a poco
van llegando vehículos privados de
personas que al lograr logrado unir de
la ciudad y es que no lo pueden hacer
directamente tienen que ir a una ciudad
de verdad es que el poder de las fuerzas
rusas allí ir pasando cada uno de esos
retenes más de 17 del ejército ruso con
las dificultades hasta poder llegar
hasta aquí hay personas que se tardan
incluso tres o cuatro días
y pasamos a las noticias de la política
francesa porque los socialistas
confirmaron un principio de acuerdo para
unirse a la coalición de los partidos de
izquierda liderada por jean luc
mélenchon y su colectivo francia
insumisa ellos están unidos ya los
ecologistas y a los comunistas que hacen
parte de la coalición con la que buscan
hacerle un contrapeso parlamentario al
presidente en manuel majón precisamente
este último se reunió este miércoles con
expertos climáticos para armar su agenda
ecológica de cara a su segundo período
de mandato precisamente el presidente
adoptó la propuesta de planificación
ecológica de melanio
una apuesta decidida por el clima
el presidente francés emmanuel maicon
reunió este miércoles en el elíseo a una
docena de expertos en clima y cambio
climático para poner en marcha su
prometida planificación ecológica a las
puertas de su segundo quinquenio está
llamada a la comunidad científica busca
sentar las bases de su proyecto en
materia medioambiental uno de los
estandartes de su campaña electoral su
post kings
santificó esos lapsos es mejor que la
comunidad científica en el sentido más
amplio participe en las decisiones se
implique en la gestión administrativa
ese es el papel del consejo superior del
clima también es el rol de una comunidad
científica como la nuestra que cuando
nos llaman los políticos podamos
responder porque he sido friki con
ficción y respondo si comenzamos con dos
macro me prometió en campaña que
convertirá a francia en la primera gran
nación libre de petróleo gas y carbón el
presidente adoptó la propuesta de
planificación ecológica de su rival
político el progresista jean-luc
mélenchon quien ya firmó un pacto con
los ecologistas de cara a las elecciones
legislativas del próximo 12 y 19 de
junio a poco más de un mes de la nueva
cita con las urnas macrón prometió a que
su nuevo primer ministro se encargará
específicamente del reto climático que
enfrenta francia o podemos sentir en
este planteamiento de manuel macro no
creo la importancia que la edad ha hecho
muchas promesas en esta materia lo vimos
en marsella y ahora se trata asimismo de
cómo pasar estas promesas a la acción
concretas los próximos cinco años van a
ser esenciales en lo que respecta a la
lucha contra el calentamiento global y
el respeto de los objetivos establecidos
en la legislación está lejos de estar
conquistado y tampoco es fácil el
gobierno francés defendió hoy su apuesta
por el clima después de que el consejo
de estado le pidiera medidas más
concretas para cumplir sus compromisos
del acuerdo de parís
la reserva federal de eeuu tomó una
decisión histórica e incrementó las
tasas de interés en medio punto
porcentual el aumento más grande que ha
habido desde el año 2000 es que el país
norteamericano enfrenta la peor
inflación en las últimas cuatro décadas
por eso la fed por sus siglas en inglés
advirtió que es probable que haya
incrementos similares de aquí a julio
para analizar este tema nos acompaña
desde florida claudio loser ex director
del hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional bienvenido a
france 24 y por favor explíquenos como
el aumento de la tasa de interés ayuda a
combatir la inflación y por qué varios
países están tomando esta medida
sí a veces suena un poco contra
intuitivo
porque uno dice cómo sube la tarjeta y
suben los costos en realidad al subir la
tasa de interés se hacen más caros los
préstamos la gente no saca préstamos
saca menos préstamos se reduce entonces
la presión para comprar y eso pone
presión hacia abajo
a la inflación lleva tiempo no es algo
que se puede hacer en un día ya están
solucionados son varios meses pero esa
es la lógica uno lo que hace es apretar
la cantidad de dinero que la gente tiene
y usted como nos cuenta el efecto se
demora un tiempo en verse y teniendo
esto en cuenta el aumento de la tasa de
interés tendrá alguna repercusión así
sea a largo plazo en las compras de la
canasta básica de los estadounidenses o
cómo se va a sentir el efecto en los
ciudadanos
bueno primeramente se va a notar por
ejemplo en las tarjetas de crédito en
los eeuu también en otros bancos
centrales no solamente este banco
central pero alguien que tiene una
tarjeta de crédito y tiene financiación
a través de la tarjeta le va a subir la
tasa de interés se le va a ser más caro
que hacer eso entonces seguramente
reducirá su compra
y eso reduce la demanda en forma más
importante alguien que quiera comprar
un auto uno o un automóvil o quiera
comprar algún artefacto de cocina o una
casa y quiere sacar un préstamo antes
pagaba dos y hace pocos meses pagaba dos
y medio 3% y en este momento ya están
pagando 5 por ciento el costo mensual de
algo así especiales de la hipoteca sube
muchísimo y eso hace que la gente gaste
y otro de los anuncios que hizo la
reserva federal de eeuu es que el
próximo mes comenzará a reducir la
reserva de activos de 9 billones de
dólares que acumuló durante la pandemia
y que esto también ayudará a combatir la
inflación explíquenos de qué se trata
esa medida
y bueno
los bancos centrales muchas veces
compran bonos de gobierno o compran
títulos o bonos de las empresas y al
comprar estas cosas como hizo en el año
2020 en el 2021 eso reduce la tasa de
interés entonces al vender y suena raro
yo sé que suena complicado al vender
estos bonos y yo no los quiero tener más
en los vende los precios van a bajar y
eso quiere decir que sube la tasa de
interés eso es baja el precio del bono
sube la tarjeta térek o sea que eso es
una cosa adicional para subir las tasas
de interés y volviendo a las tasas de
interés esto puede tener algunas
repercusiones en la economía
latinoamericana y también la economía
mundial
la respuesta muy breve es sí
en américa latina porque sube la tasa
interés en eeuu sube el dólar al subir
el dólar eso quiere decir que digamos en
argentina o en brasil o en mexico la
moneda se deprecia y entonces pierdes
digamos se debilite y para compensar eso
para compensar esa situación los bancos
centrales normalmente suben las tasas de
interés para estar en línea con los eeuu
también el banco central europeo lo va a
hacer no creo que el banco de japón el
banco de inglaterra y otro banco más
también o sea esto tiene un impacto
mundial importante de reducción en las
presiones inflacionarias es un remedio
que duele es un remedio que duele pero
hay que tomar el remedio
claudio lo hacer gracias por explicarnos
estas noticias económicas aquí en france
24 y pasamos a otra información
gracias pasamos a otra información
porque vuelven los apagones en cuba
según informó la empresa eléctrica
este miércoles estaban planeadas
interrupciones en la energía de 10 de
los 15 municipios de la habana que
estaban programadas para durar 8 horas
el trasfondo es que apagones similares
fueron una de las causas de las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
empezaron el 11 de julio de 2021 la
demanda de energía se dispara en la isla
de los meses más cálidos que están por
llegar
y el jefe de la droga en colombia fue
extraditado a eeuu como lo confirmó el
presidente colombiano iván duque se
trata de dairo antonio úsuga alias
otoniel el máximo líder del clan del
golfo la justicia estadounidense lo
requiere por narcotráfico en abril la
corte suprema de justicia de colombia
avaló su extradición pero la semana
pasada el consejo de estado la suspendió
pues las víctimas del grupo armado
alegaba que sus crímenes quedarían en la
impunidad ahora el mismo consejo de
estado levantó la prohibición para
extraditarlo y tan sólo horas después el
gobierno envió a alias otoniel a eeuu
este miércoles y jueves serán las
celebraciones por el aniversario número
74 de la creación del estado de israel
el primer ministro naftalí bennett
lideró un llamado a la unidad repetido
por los líderes políticos israelíes sin
embargo la fecha está marcada por la
dualidad porque para muchos árabes
recuerda el éxodo palestino forzado por
el establecimiento del estado judío
nuestro corresponsal en jerusalén
federico cual barberena nos tiene más
información
día 5 de liar en el calendario hebreo y
del luto por el recuerdo de sus soldados
caídos y víctimas del terrorismo israel
pasa a celebrar el aniversario 74 de la
creación de su estado la conmemoración
de este año ocurre de la noche del
miércoles a la jornada del jueves inició
con el encendido de antorchas en el
monte herzl y cuenta con diversos
eventos culturales y la realización de
picnics barbacoas y conciertos entre
otros actos de que por primera vez en
dos años se desarrollan casi sin
restricciones por la pandemia
esto es muy emocionante extrañaba a
salir a las calles y celebrar israel
para mí israel significa independencia y
libertad para ser judía para estar en la
calle y estar orgulloso de mí y de mis
creencias
a esta fecha el gobierno israelí llega
al mando de una coalición con inédita
presencia árabe algo destacado por el
primer ministro naftalí bennett en su
mensaje aunque marcado por su fragilidad
y lejos de estar dispuesto a un diálogo
serio que resuelva el conflicto entre
israelíes y palestinos para estos
últimos este día no es de festejo o
independencia sino que marca la nakba o
catástrofe en referencia al hecho de
forzado que cientos de miles de
palestinos sufrieron desde la guerra
árabe-israelí de 1948 hasta hoy
si me preguntas por mis sentimientos
como árabe este es mi país y no me
siento tranquilo porque vivo en
condiciones difíciles sobre todo con los
judíos
no nos sentimos con libertad de ir a
donde queramos y hacer lo que queramos
y de nuevo agua
la controversia en torno a este día
sumar a este jueves una exhibición de la
fuerza aérea israelí que planea
sobrevolar hebrón en la cisjordania
ocupada un movimiento catalogado de
provocación por la izquierda israelí y
organizaciones palestinas
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]